demi lovato congratulate s' X Joe Jonas
on his engagement plus Jimmy Kimmel
shares an update on his son's heart
condition hello everyone I'd like to
propose a toast to a good week ahead and
another for Joe Jonas and sophie Turner
that's right
hearts everywhere are broken now because
Joe and Sophie are officially off the
market but we're happy for them right
the two shared the exciting engagement
news on Instagram both posting this shot
of her gorgeous rock so if he wrote I
said yes while Joe confirmed it in his
caption quote she said yes the dnc
frontman and Game of Thrones star have
been linked since November 2016
but you'd barely know it because they
keep their couple ship pretty private
still everyone is so happy for them
they're famous family and friends came
out of the woodwork following their
engagement including get this Joe's ex
Demi Lovato who follows Sophie on
Instagram shortly after commenting on
their post quote huge congrats so happy
for the both of you
Joe's brother Nick couldn't contain his
excitement posting ah congratulations to
my brother and sister-in-law to be on
your engagement I love you both so much
not to be outdone
Sophie's BFF and Game of Thrones co-star
Maisie Williams wrote congratulations to
my beautiful girlfriend on her
engagement this is just one of many life
milestones we'll share love you both so
it's officially a race to the altar
between Joe and Sophie and Sophie's
co-stars Kit Harington and Rose Leslie
who got engaged in September all right
moving on to the trailer everybody is
talking about black panther the official
trailer dropped today and set to vince
staples back back it is a sight to
behold and from the looks of it we may
have Marvel's most breathtaking movie
yet you going to be
don't please
I never freeze
[Music]
cuz we
and that is just a taste you guys we
have the full trailer up now at et
online.com but the visual effects
obviously look next-level in this but as
sterling K Brown told us Black Panther
is so much more than an action film man
this script is so great it's wonderful
it is I mean it gives you all the action
that you anticipate from a Marvel film
but it's got a wonderful social story
very socially relevant timely story at
the center of it Ryan Coogler I'd run
through a wall for you brother
good times it's a shame we have to wait
until Black Panther claws into theatres
February 16th but something tells me it
will be worth the wait
now speaking of social relevance eats he
was with Oprah over the weekend in fact
about 400 famous faces were invited to
her home
also known as the promised land for a
Sunday Gospel Brunch it was all to
celebrate the launch of her new book
wisdom of Sunday's Andy tease Nancy
O'Dell got a special invite what I
wanted to do was condense all of my
favorite aha moment into one book which
is like nearly impossible because you've
had so many aha yes but these are aha
moments I've had with supersoul guests
and so you know everybody talks now
about let's get woke let's stay woke
this is how you start it's a it's about
awakening and it's about following your
own spiritual GPS that everybody has and
it's about learning how to forgive and
it's about grace and gratitude it's
about all the things that I've been
talking about for years that really
matter
condensed in this little package that
sits by my bedside table and every time
I look at it it makes me happy so I'm
having an aha moment and you know for me
it really is true that when I discover
something that I love I want to share it
with other people and you know so I
didn't do this book to make money
because I'm giving all of the money away
to you know every single dime I make
will go to helping girls learn and so
this is just an it's my offering to the
world yes sitting on my desk here at the
office you guys is a sign that reads
Oprah wasn't built in a day and ain't
that the truth you give us so much inspo
oh all right from one inspiring TV
personality to another
Jimmy Kimmel poured his soul in front of
millions of Americans back in May when
he opened up about his five-month-old
son Billy who underwent a life-saving
heart surgery shortly after he was born
today Jimmy is sharing an update on his
son's heart condition with et's Kevin
Frazier son doing how everything good
with him he's doing great he's he's a
fat little baby and he's he's getting
big he's gonna have to have another
operation soon and but everything's
going great so far we despite the
outpouring of love that night people
have never forgotten that night it was a
amazing night when you gave that
monologue and talked about your son you
touch so many people is that something
you always remember um yeah I mean yeah
how could you forget something like that
I mean that's it was people were so nice
and people still are so nice everybody
you know they come up to me to ask me
how Billy is and then you know and it's
it's really nice to see to get that from
people and I think it's the result of
you know just being on television for
many years and you feel like you know
somebody and and it you know people say
they're praying it means a lot it does
Jimmy is currently in Brooklyn where he
will be taping Jimmy Kimmel Live all
week long we have more with Jimmy and
Oprah tonight on ET Plus these stories
are more up now on ET online.com so
thank you guys for watching hit
subscribe and we'll be back tomorrow
with a brand new daily denne love to you
all